discoveries that shook the world
[Music]
well what's happened to black holes
collided a long long time ago and the
amazing thing is that no humans existed
when black holes collided but why the
waves travel through the universe Homo
sapiens develop on earth and by the time
the waves reach the earth we know not
only existed but had developed
instruments which was sufficiently
sensitive to detect this tiny tiny
vibration when the gravitational waves
were parts where was the collision so
the collision was four hundred mega
parsec away
we don't know which galaxy it was
exactly but we know that it was 1.3
billion light-years away which is quite
far away but it's very difficult to
pinpoint the location exactly because
the detectors we have are not very
sensitive directional so they can point
to an arc on the sky we might have
happened but cannot say exactly that
this was
it might happen closer to us in in the
near future but we are getting so few
gravitational wave at this at this time
but I cannot tell you when we'll see
something which is even closer dangerous
for us this will probably not be
dangerous for us unless earth would
collide with a black hole which which is
not going to happen anytime soon
but the effect is so tremendously small
and here we're talking about trillions
of a millimeter on a length which is the
size of the diameter of the earth but
this is not something which an ordinary
human which he would even feel this is
why we need is extremely sensitive
instrument so even when they arrived at
Earth
nobody could just feel it just true us
so we believe that there are
gravitational wave sweeping through the
earth all the time now now if we're
lucky and the amplitude is slightly
larger when we are able to detect them
but mostly we are not even able to see
them what was this sound of the
gravitational wave like
also the point is and I want to stress
that that gravitational waves are not
sound but the waveform has wiggles in
them and if you look at these Wiggles
and how they vary over time you can
represent what you see in terms of an
audible signal and this was the chair of
weeaboo just so it so happens the
frequency of this waveforms is almost
the range of human hearing and this is
my wrist we're saying that the
gravitational waves allowed so what was
the main achievement of this year's
Lawrence competencies are quite
complimentary rain of ice is the founder
of the whole project he developed the
concept starting in the beginning or the
middle of the 1960s he built the first
prototype detectors in 1967 and then he
demonstrated the principle he charted
the various noise sources which would
influence the performance of the
detector and as I've been trying to
mention the detect is incredibly
sensitive a truck passing by will make
the detector vibrate motion waves some
distance away make also the detective
vibrate say small or do other things so
you have to know very very well what
kind of sources can give you signals
which simulates gravitational wave to be
able to distinguish the true from the
false so his main influence on the
project is
developing a prototype chartering all
the sources of disturbances and finding
means to offset these sources thorn is
this inspiring theorist who figured out
what kind of signals you can expect from
Astrophysical sources of these waves so
what to look for how sensitive does the
instrument have to be to be able to
observe what the universe behaves like
in terms of gravitational waves and then
we have very bearish he's the person who
joined the experimental label he only
arrived on the scene in 1994 however he
is the visionary behind upgrading the
sensitivity of the instrument to the
level when this detection was possible
the original liger could not have made
the detection which was possible thanks
to the development initiated by very
bearish worked like for 50 years with
this project well what did they say when
they got the call from Stockholm this
morning well I think they were expecting
it more or less as I said at the press
conference the first discovery of a
gravitational wave the first direct
measurement caused the sensation
worldwide so it's been speculated
already for a year that this was a
deserving discovery and so I think they
were half expecting it they were still
humbled and very very gratified that
they
we're awarded the prize but also all
three of them mentioned one that they
were happy that they were not alone and
two that we should make sure to stress
the role of the collaboration at the
press conference and I'm gonna be awards
so how was this collaboration the lack
of collaboration yes the line of
collaboration has grown over the last 14
years in the beginning it was small it
was just groups at MIT and the Caltech
at the universities in the United States
but then as the detector grew in size
and people started talking of kilometer
long arms
the collaboration also grew and groups
joined all across the United States but
also in Europe and in Australia so today
the light of collaboration consists of
scientists at 90 universities all across
the world so you are going to invite to
stock on my cousin scientists
unfortunately I don't think it is
possible but each Nobel laureate has the
opportunity of inviting a certain number
of peoples I hope that we'll get
representatives from across the
collaboration so no word when the
gravitational waves are here in some
sense what will they tell us about the
universe so what we hope to learn from
the gravitational waves is
one about black holes and about gravity
in a strong regime you have to imagine
gravity as the weakest force from north
it's much weaker than electromagnetism
just think of a kitchen magnet a small
magnet you put on the door of your
fridge it stays up it doesn't fall to
the ground it just shows you that the
electromagnetism is much stronger than
gravity so the gravity forces we know of
from the earth a weak gravitational
forces close to black holes extremely
strong so the discovery of gravitational
waves carrying information from the
surroundings of black holes will teach
us something about the strong regime of
gravity which is very very exciting
we'll learn something about violent
explosions like supernovae or gamma-ray
bursts we might learn something about
the Big Bang because the Big Bang left
imprint on the universe in terms of
gravitational waves which we've never
seen before they're even weaker than
those which have been observed
previously but even more exciting
they're part of the universe which are
dark which you've never seen before
because electromagnetic radiation
doesn't reach us from there
gravitational waves are unstoppable so
they will so we hope to learn about this
dark thank you very much for taking your
time with us